[موسيقى]
biophilia
قد لا تعرف المصطلح ولكنك تعرف
ما يعنيه أن الرغبة
في السير في متنزه في يوم مشمس
أو الاستماع إلى صوت جدول ثرثار
يتعلق بجاذبية البشر الفطرية
للطبيعة والعمليات الطبيعية  بطريقة
ما يفسر نوعًا ما لماذا عندما نرغب في
الذهاب في عطلة نتوجه إلى الشواطئ
والجبال والغابات لأننا
نعلم أنه عندما نقضي وقتًا في الطبيعة ، فإن
لديها القدرة على تقليل التوتر
وتعافينا
هذه القدرة على التعافي هي  أحد المشاكل التي
يدمجها المهندسون المعماريون والمصممين بشكل متزايد في تخصصهم
واصفة إياه بالتصميم المحب للأحياء إحدى
المشاكل هي أننا نعيش الآن في
بيئات حضرية مبنية عندما نعيش في
مساحات هندسية حضرية صاخبة
ونفصلها عن الأشياء
التي تهمنا أكثر
إذا  تتضمن البيئات الحضرية
فرصًا للتواصل مع الطبيعة
التي ستؤثر حقًا على صحة
ورفاهية سكان الحضر.
بدعة جديدة ، تُظهر
مجموعة من الدراسات العلمية الآن كيف
توجد صلة بين جلب الطبيعة
إلى محيطنا
والنتائج الإيجابية لأجسامنا وعقولنا ، على
سبيل المثال ، هناك علاقة بين
المرضى في المستشفيات الذين يتطلعون إلى
الطبيعة وأوقات تعافي أقصر
عندما  إنهم يتعافون في الضوء الطبيعي
، يمكنهم القيام بذلك باستخدام 22 دواء أقل
ويمكن أن يشعروا بألم أقل بشكل لا يصدق ،
لذلك تبحث الكثير من الشركات في
هذا الأمر وتدرك أن هناك
حالة عمل قوية جدًا لجلب النباتات
والمساحات الخضراء إلى المساحات التي لا تحتاج إليها
المصمم الداخلي
لدمج التصميم الحيوي في الفضاء الخاص بك ،
يعد الضوء الطبيعي أمرًا أساسيًا
لإيقاعات الساعة البيولوجية لأجسامنا والتي هي
ردود فعل أجسامنا على فترات الضوء
والظلام خلال فترة 24 ساعة ، فهي تؤثر على
مزاجنا وسلوكنا
وإفراز هرمون الجسم للميلاتونين  والسيروتونين ،
لذلك عندما نتعرض جيدًا
للضوء الطبيعي ، فهذا يعني أنه
يمكننا النوم جيدًا في الليل ثم
نستيقظ  الشعور بمزيد من
النباتات المنتعشة أيضًا ، هذه الأشياء الأكثر روعة
التي يمكنها إزالة السموم ، يمكنها
تعديل درجة الحرارة والرطوبة ،
ستساعدك النباتات الداخلية على العناية
بها واستثمار مشاعرك بها.
المساحات الخضراء في
المساحات التي
أنشأناها ، النصيحة الثالثة هي التفكير في المشهد الصوتي الخاص بك إذا كانت المساحة حية وجذابة ،
فيمكننا بسهولة تشتيت انتباهنا
إذا كنت تفكر في الاستماع إلى
صوت المياه الجارية في جدول قريب
أو صوت الغناء  الطيور في
شجرة قريبة كل تلك اللحظات من
المحفزات الإيجابية توفر
فرصًا لجذب انتباهك
من الإجهاد الداخلي والألم الذي
لديك إلى روعة
الاتصال بالطبيعة ،
فإن استخدام المواد مهم حقًا ،
وهناك بعض الأبحاث المثيرة للاهتمام حقًا
حول الاستخدام  من الأخشاب ، لديه في
الواقع القدرة على التأثير على استجابتك الفسيولوجية
للمساحة
، حيث قارنت دراسة في سلوفاكيا مع كلينيكا  كانت
غرفة الانتظار المصنوعة من الخشب مع واحدة مصنوعة
من مرضى
صفائحيين أكثر هدوءًا وأقل إجهادًا في
الغرفة الخشبية وكلما مكثوا هناك لفترة أطول ،
أصبحت أدمغتهم أكثر نشاطًا
وأقل خوفًا وعصبية
وزادت ذاكرتهم وقدرتهم على التفكير.
5 -
التفكير في اللون في حياتك
فالألوان الزرقاء مهدئة جدا
ومنعش لأنها تذكرنا
ببرك الماء الهادئة
في الحضارة المصرية القديمة
كان هناك تقدير للون الأخضر
فهو لون النمو والازدهار
والصحة والرفاهية.  حتى الإحساس
بالمتعة والفرح ،
فإن التصميم الحيوي للأحياء يتعلق حقًا
بالبقاء المشترك وإحياء الإنسان والأرض ،
إنه نقطة انطلاق لإحساس بيئي أوسع
بالمسؤولية والاهتمام ويشجعنا على أن نصبح
مواطنين على هذا الكوكب بدلاً من
المحتلين السلبيين
[موسيقى  ]